bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi siamo
di nuovo su penombra scusatemi se è da
tanto che non faccio penombra
però avevo altri impegni da portare
avanti adesso ho iniziato la roma
rimasti che erano soliti qui non mi
ricordo come è ok e crolla tutto mi
sembra giusto da un altra scelta se non
continuare qualunque cosa abbia
progettato questa galleria che incluso
l'instabilità come optional grosso se
prima mi faro piuttosto insetto di
affido non mi piace il modo in cui si
muovono neanche a me comunque ragazzi
non ho idea di che di che cosa guardo a
trovare qua dentro per non mi piace per
stato un importo sta diventando bassa
ostri rocco la galleria questa questa
una roccia inutile
cazzo
oddio no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
io detesto i ragni ragazzino mi fa
schifo
no no mi fa troppo schifo mi fa troppo
schifo mi fa troppo schifo
no no no mi fanno schifo e ragni ragazzi
mi fanno troppo schifo
no vabbè allora ragazzi se è così non
non ci riesco a mera anni fanno
veramente schifo sono aracnofobia dalla
nascita non ci riesco se è così
veramente ragazzi non ci riesco a
cercare di uscire da questo punto prima
possibile
no no no no aspetta fammi chiudere qui
perché non mi piace ok non basta vero
[Musica]
non penso sia così potente da riuscire a
spostare una roccia enorme infatti no
vabbè no seriamente ragazzi a me fanno
veramente troppo sifo cos'è sta roba
spero spero siano di animale ma sono
alquanto scettico deve uscire da qua che
schifo
dove vado in bagno di qua
speriamo che non si schiudano no no no
no non mi piace devo uscire di qua
ragazzi no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
kat
togli togliti non arrivano no arriva
rioni arriva a cazzo se forse ce l'ho
fatta no speriamo che non passino no non
ci credo proprio che tornati indietro
via via via via via via via via via
prima che arrivi no non mi piace
sinistra basca [ __ ]
no
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo la è che balle
che palle ma tu sono tornati indietro
non ci credo
forse riesco a ok corri corri corri
corri corri corri corpo
la forza forza forza forza forza
[Musica]
ok forse ce l'ho fatta ragazzi forse
forse ce l'ho fatta
poi crollare il ponte fa qualcosa basta
che non arrivano o cazzo corri
oddio di oddio no
ma come mi chiama ceva passava di lì c'è
troppo piccolo
forse ce la faccio ragazzi forse sì vai
se sei il mio piccolo non ce la fa
comunque se macerie sono un uomo morto
cazzo corri invece sì che ce la devi
fare sì sì corri corri corri corico a
risentire anni dietro ragazzi sentire
ogni dietro standard dai oggi posso
credere
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
no dai io ci sono ci sono sì sì sì
scusate non si stava scusatemi ragazzi
ma ci stava ma affanculo io tupper è
ancora il buco per sicurezza un
repellente per insetti dove mi state
dicendo che non potevo anche non passare
di lì poteva arrivare qui la tramite
un'altra strada e mi state dicendo che
questo pd parla l'auricolare mi ha preso
per il culo se io riesco a uscire di qui
ea trovare quello che mi parla ma quanto
cazzo ti tiro che non avete idea
veramente c'è mi sta sul culo più che
mai questo qui allora ha detto che ce
l'abbia repellente ferragni qua dentro
così nel caso mi trovano forse questo
antidolorifici ma è già qualcosa
se c'è il repellente per ragni me lo
mangio piuttosto allora non kg rifici ci
siamo come prima come si fa a salvare un
micro più raga ab e saab in automatico
babbo non so ragazzi servizi a ecco
minchia erano due ore che tentavo di
aspettate un attimo quassù non vi posso
alzare però no ok allora sentimenti
interno avendo come sfondo tutto daccapo
che novità di due morti ok ok per massa
senza non non l'avevo vista prima
invece qua niente ci deve ma quando
riesco proprio ad alzarmi ragazzi non si
può rialzare solo in piedi
vabbè pazienza sostanza non avevo vista
prima ragazzi allora
piccone via a posto ho finito le pile
della torcia quindi fantastico c'è
ragione perché questo vecchio braccio
meccanico non debba più funzionare non
funziona però scommetto quello che
volete che non funziona intanto salviamo
perché se mi perdo i salvataggi dove
ripartire da lì non continuerò più
penombra piuttosto va bene un libro che
richard benson quello sul libro anticipo
mitologie eschimese lettura cristiana
pubblicata 1903 ok non aveva senso quel
libro ragazzi speravo ci fossero delle
istruzioni ma a si muove aspettate è che
ci faccio questa roba
[Musica]
forse ho capito forse però
devo utilizzarla come scala per arrivare
lassù forse allora facciamo così ragazzi
allora quante volte ho detto allora
metto questo qua aspettate no
più indietro più indietro ok non è che
ci arrivò già così ci prova e non penso
proprio vai no quasi però devo per forza
utilizzare quello come scala allora
aspettate un attimo che provo a sono un
genio anche se cosa ragazzi quindi di
sicuro ci metterò mezz'ora però spero di
non fare brutta figura
innanzitutto alziamo poi no no
mamma mia che violenza ok fermo la fermo
che hai forse fosse già ci siamo così ci
prova vado ok ole ole incredibile ci
sono riuscita al primo colpo ragazzi
ok è qui dentro
va bene cerco di andare ok perfetto e
quindi non ci sono altri ragni vero no
perché l'ultima volta che sono passato
in dei condotti che non erano condotti
ma vabbè c'erano ragni ok sostanza non
l'avevo vista prima quindi perfetto
scendo va bene
stando a red dovrei trovare anche una
chiave deve essere qui intorno
proviamo quello si chiama red ce l'ho
con lui fino alla morte
sappiatelo che era che attorno indietro
perché evidentemente bell'affare lì non
non serve cioè non devo passarci adesso
premente c passerò più avanti
ho trovato intanto una tanica di benzina
che non dovete chiedermi che cosa serve
perché non ne ho la più pallida idea
torno indietro allora di dio ci sono già
passato di da gran peggio non si lava
sono arrivato di qua
ma non un addio ma ero mano che idiota
ma veramente allora sono state [ __ ]
ragazzi cioè io pensavo che quella fosse
una nuova zona nonchè che fosse quella
di prima d'ora qui evidentemente e da
dove poteva cadere
ok non avevo capito raga che
che dovevo fare il giro allora boa posto
devo prendere soltanto la tanica solo la
chiave non ho idea di dove sia a qui ho
aperto la porta che era bloccata
perfetto manca
avevo visto mi ricordo prima ecco tipo
questa so che non si apriva dalla prova
a sfondare la vediamo se sfondati
togliti è che cazzo aspettate ok chiave
grande sono quasi sicuro che le cifre
chiave come a questa chiave è a questa
tanica di benzina e adesso che c'è
questo che faccio adesso è
effettivamente sia la chiave che la
tanica e che cosa faccio da fuoco i cani
che non sarebbe una brutta idea fra
l'altro anzi veniamo subito se riesco no
vabbè che ci finisco bruciato come
l'ultima volta quindi meglio di no però
lo porto dietro perché non si sa mai
vediamo se riesco a portarmi dietro no
no ok perfetto faccio così va
non so dove devo andare ragazzi non ne
ho la più pallida idea che faccio prima
a farlo a lanciarlo ogni volta che hai
perfetto così a me non corro piano piano
piano c'e nessuno era pieno di cani una
volta qui non c'è più nessun beh meglio
a me non è che dà fastidio ok via libera
va bene non so dove sto andando però ci
sono di sicuro alle porte che non ho
ancora visto cos'è questo a differenza
degli altri è ok
non mi piace non sa se sei una sega
perfetto la cosa mi serve a una sega era
pessima ragazzi ma non so che cosa fa
linee della tanica né della chiave e ne
lista seca aspettate un attimo però qui
non è che si può si sa mai spacchiamo le
porte ma non quello questo cos'è non
vedo perché dovrebbe funzionare
non vedo perché dovrebbe funzionare
ancora che allora perfetto non mi
interessa anche perché non so che cosa
mi dovrei fare soprattutto
dove sono io ad ora in fondo
non posso andare avanti a meno che non
debba usare ho capito ma che idiota ma
che idiota sono ma dai mi chiamò la sega
forse non serve proprio a una sega a
qualcosa serve di sicuro
aspettate adesso provo se riesco bene se
non riesco a me c'è l'altro cane ragionò
non basta che non me lo trovo davanti
che già sono messo male
ok vai forse devo fare così non ne sono
sicuro se ci metto tanto ragazze capirle
se cose ma alla fine ci arrivò anch'io
state tranquilli chiudiamo perfetto
promette bene ragazzi promette il
terremoto mi invoglia ad entrare qua
dentro allora o cazzo lo shooter
partiamo malissimo cela un'esplosiva può
tornare utile come fonte di luce no non
mi serve a niente come fonte di luce
allora speriamo che non si svegli
di girare non ti girare ok
perfetto tutti uguali sì posti ragazzi
che fantasia e c'hanno neo di qua anche
perché nei posti di prima non penso che
debba fare qualcos'altro
prova a farlo fuori ci prova dai al
massimo al massimo niente devo riuscirci
cazzo no
oddio dimmi che muore ma cazzo
no no no no ok ok va bene che cazzo sei
ok perfetto un altro salve
ok ragazzi sono un genio sono [ __ ]
genio mamma mia è caduto
che culo allora adesso devo fare alla
rambo tipo se sale celone culo non
salire non salerno
[Applauso]
attacco combinato ragazzi si uniscono
per uccidermi combinano gli attacchi un
altro po ci manca che fanno la fusione
come in dragonball devo devo riuscire a
proseguire senza farmi ammazzare
possibilmente allora qui non ce ne è
pieno di sti cosi però è difficile
ucciderli sti cazzo di cani quindi
meglio non usarli cioè sono in caso di
necessità almeno vediamo innanzitutto
dove riusciamo ad arrivare di qua non
c'è niente dov'è che siamo più solo
precisare ok e devo per forza superarli
ragazzi come faccio ci prova di altri è
un sono qua
correte
oddio non si è accorto di niente o
invece se n'è accorto
ok ok forse riesco a farlo esplodere no
perfetto allora via via salita
ok no no ok piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano
ok sta chiamando rinforzi devo riuscire
a correre e superiori di salvarmi
dove sono
[Musica]
[Applauso]
al mio tre ragazzi uno che stanno
facendo cos'è un attacco combinato 123
vai
si no
ok forse riesco a no no no no è che
cazzo si è madonna che potenza ciao
[Musica]
mamma mia che jumper riuscire ad
arrivare ma che vada di scatole di
scarpe da ragazzi
ok grazie spingi video bravo ancora
ancora bravo così può pilan non indietro
non indietro
ok vai vai spingimi così
[Musica]
ok ok basta basta un passo alla volta
[Applauso]
l'altro cane se n'è andato filippo
questa abbastanza tranquillo a quello
ok già quasi watt
fatevi dare una botta al suo cane che
madonna che letta prendi prendi prendi
prendi prendi
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no sì che lo ragazzi devo devo
datemi p4
[Applauso]
dai che il piccolo e meno
grandissimo ma è un prete vai così corri
corri cuore scorri no no no no no no
ok
sono miracolosamente riuscito a salvarmi
con quanto con tutta la mia non mi hanno
neanche toccato questa deve essere punto
di accesso per non ho fatto in tempo a
leggere [ __ ] il punto di accesso
per qualcosa intanto salvo ragazzi
perché qui sto uscendo matto allora del
resto non sono ancora morte infatti è
capito che coca ma non ti fa niente
tuttavia deve essere qualche funziona ma
che il ragazzo salvato
una cabina energetica filpi c'ero
arrivato anch'io devo fare qualcosa qui
raga perché non
cos'è questo non c'è corrente nel
pannello di controllo
non ho idea di che cosa debba fare però
ragazzi non sa cos'è questo
so che cosa devo fare qui cos'è sta roba
una rossi fa ok magari riesco a uscire
proprio dal a scappare da penombra
problema che è un macchinario di tutto
rispetto non credo ci siano mezzi
industriali più grandi quei denti sulla
parte anteriore sembrano ben affilati
intera macchina un aspetto piuttosto
aggressivo
il problema è che non si può guidare
e allora che cosa mi serve è vero dico
io a una minchia cosa ci sono venuto a
fare qui i ragazzi spiegate nei loro
perché non ci trova un senso o sta roba
serve proprio a c'è la sfida della
corrente fantastico dove la devo ficcare
sta roba
non c'è pace qui la presa vai vai tipo
quando collego il caricabatteria del
telefono vai così perfetta adesso
funziona è comodo non va neanche a pile
aa ok prodotto premere c'è devo tirare
questo non c'è corrente nel pannello di
controllo non rompere le palle funziona
qualcosa ogni tanto devo fare tutto io
finemente
no collegata alla spina cosa vuole
adesso
ma mi sta prendendo per il culo
ma scherzi no ragazzi ma siamo scherza
cioè non ci arriva allora io sto a fare
dove lo dovrei collegare a ok perfetto
non c'era arrivato ragazzi non ci arriva
se cosa ci metto più tempo al corrente
attiva ma non succede nulla
come mai non sono sorpreso wow
questa destra stazioni controllo per una
mostruosità gialla e non succede un
cazzo va beh forse due filaci la chiave
non è che forse dove infilarci la chiave
ragazzi però non so dove anche con la
chiave inserita non non ne vuole sapere
di avviarsi la macchina deve avere
qualcosa che non va mamma mia quanto per
cambiare ragazzi non sempre cose diverse
ragazzi sempre delle sorprese in questo
videogame non me lo sarei mai aspettato
comunque non è che devo aspetta un
attimo che qua c'è
la scavatrice non parte che sia senza
benzina ciò anche quella
il problema è che non so dove mettere la
benzina in sta roba cioè io non guido
però evidentemente non è una normale
macchina forse questo cioè non so dove
dove infilarci la benzina ragazzi cielo
ma non so dove metterla nella metto sul
tetto a caso la lucina bloccato e
coperchi lelat della benzina ma io
troveremo dovrà più dati mettere solo
qui per troppo tempo
qual è il tappo della benzina tra tutti
questi minchia un ora cosa ho fatto non
ho capito neanche io ho iniziato a fare
cose a caso ho unito il martello con la
benzina fantastico non so neanche che
cosa ho fatto ma va bene così come
direbbe mio amico bevi bestie assetata
sì bravo non si simpatico laraia sta
trasmettendo cosa vuoi stronzo cerchia
ritene su queste miserie qui anche per
rendere liberi nati verità che sa che
stamani ha condotti sotto i crolli il
cielo se guardi bene mi ci trovo anch'io
ma guarda per me poi anche restarci per
quanto viola
dai è partita la faremo
oddio
va bene vado vado stai zitto non ti
voglio ascoltare
evvai
cioè sfondiamo tutto ragazza potenza
tanto questo parlato bene
ok ragazzi dovrebbe bastare così
dov'è che siamo non so neanche io però
io spero che indietro non si debba
ritornare perché non c'è più voglia di
fare giri a caso perché non so più che
cosa fare
penso che siamo arrivati in una nuova
zona completamente inesplorata quindi
indietro non ci devo ritornare almeno
spero preghiamo perché non mi piaceva
più il posto perfetto
questo non è che tanto meglio terremoti
come al solito sembra presa si fanno mi
sono mai spinto così in profondità ma
guarda non c'entrare perché non mi
sembra proprio l'ideale non funziona più
da torcia perché un ora che sto premendo
il tasto f ma non voglio capirlo che non
c'ho le batterie si apre e non si apre
con addio ragazzo io che ma che cazzo
essere roba
uniti oddio
mio zio macchina
che schifo è un verme trovò ricollegati
si infilano nei di scappini a c'è ma
sorpreso ragazzi questo me l'aspettavo
ma perché un verme così enorme dovrebbe
trovarsi nelle miniere ragazzi manco le
miniere di moria erano così profonda
questa porta e sigillata da una maniglia
come viene aperta volete state dove
conduce non lo so non mi interessa fammi
uscire di qua allora ragazzino come idea
di che cosa debba fare vado di qua speri
non incontrare altri vermi perché quello
di prima mi è bastato no no dai di nuovo
no è di nuovo no no no no no
[Musica]
sono riuscito a semi madonna chiudi sono
riusciti a seminarlo non ci posso che
avevo perso le speranze ragazzi ormai
pensavo di morire perché non credevo di
potermi salvare così invece ci sono
riuscito vai
ok tiriamo stare ma non so che cosa
serve
ma sa qual cosa servirà
sì
che cazzo servita ok penso di aver
capito forse sta leva ragazzi apre la
porta a quella iniziale l'unico problema
è che lì non è un posto tanto pacifico
credo
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] corri corri con forti
chiudi chiudi la madonna mia se riuscito
a salvarmi di modi di un pelo però
ragazzi non so come fare
cieli e pieno di ragni e non voglio
passare le persone non perché ci sono i
ragni store gioco non bastavano i cani
anche i ragni potevano metterci le
farfalle no ai ragni ok ragazzi ci provo
lo stesso devo andare a tutta velocità
che tanto non posso fare altrimenti dai
ci provo vai
[Musica]
chiudo gli occhi e se mi ritrovai
davanti chiudo gli occhi cielo che non
vedo chi doveva dov'ero ok
meno male che sono dietro a me non ti do
gli occhi però mi raggiungono così
sicuro io aggiungo ai chiudi ti porta di
merda